[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's uh hit the wayback
machine let me go back 24 hours ago so
we bring in booger mcfarland espn nfl
and college football analyst if i said
the likelihood that russell wilson was
on the move or aaron rodgers was on the
move
what would you have said booger
uh good morning dad good morning
probably that it was aaron rodgers i
think we all expected aaron rodgers to
be on the move basically in the last uh
really two years with all the
um
us not knowing what was gonna happen all
the hard feelings but it seemed like
there was an epiphany up in green bay
and everybody
uh kind of got on the same page so i
think that's why it was a shocker that
aaron stayed and then the blockbuster a
little while later that russell was
leaving
if i said to denver john elway you can
have aaron rodgers or russell wilson
who would you take
oh that's not even the question i take
the guy that's won four mvps over the
guy that hadn't gotten a single mvp vote
to me it's not even close but if i look
at the longevity that i could have
russell wilson as opposed to aaron
rodgers do i factor in age in that uh
that answer you can you can factor that
in but i think you could ask the
buccaneers if they factor in age when
they chose tom brady or vice versa tom
brady chose them they just took the best
quarterback at the time and they got a
super bowl out of it and i think they're
really really happy now it puts him in a
position now that brady has retired that
they're looking for a quarterback but
they can always go into the trophy case
and look at that lombardi in that super
bowl ring so aaron rodgers is a better
quarterback but what russell wilson does
then is when i as a player if i'm on
that team when i go to training camp now
i know we got a guy that gives me
a better than a puncher's chance like we
got hope to know we can compete with
kansas city the chargers the las vegas
raiders in our own division uh before we
even get to the rest of the afc or the
rest of the nfl
if i said this and it's a snarky poll
question more likely to appear in the
super bowl next year russell wilson or
tom brady
uh more likely to i well did just based
on odds the fact that
the fact that one of my odds is not even
currently playing in the nfl i'm gonna
have to take russell wilson but if tom
brady were to come back and be on a
viable team let's just say for instance
since we're in this nice imaginary world
uh the buccaneers or the 49ers yeah
those two teams would vault ahead of the
broncos
which move did you not like yesterday
i think sometimes over over my lifetime
dan and probably yours how many times
have we seen a a person or a situation
just kind of wear its course we saw it
with andy reid in philadelphia we've
seen it with uh tom brady in new england
i i thought we got to a point where
aaron rodgers in green bay kind of
wanted kind of won his quarters to time
to one out and both sides needed to
change because you know that those
feelings haven't always been on the same
page now i know we're going to the same
kumbaya they're going to give him 45 to
50 million a year and everybody's gonna
say everything is great but then you
like me have probably had hard feelings
to a person or for a person and we say
yep i forgive you and we move on but are
those feelings really gone are they ever
really gonna do we just suppress them
based on
something that happened or based on our
our decision to
to to just move on i just wonder if it
doesn't go well in green bay let's say
for instance and i i do not foresee this
because i think they're going to walk
away with that division i think they're
going to win 13 games but let's just say
for instance something's happened
happens bad and they don't get off to a
good start and brian bootikins does
something that aaron doesn't like you
think those feelings are going to come
back up let's say cut somebody let's say
it cuts random cardboard cut somebody
that they aren't really likes you think
those hard feelings are going to come
back up i do and so i just think at some
point there's a time you move on and i
thought the time was now for green bay
and aaron to move on more pressure on
russell wilson
or aaron rodgers this next season
i think it's more pressure on aaron
because aaron is in a familiar
consistent position they've won 13 games
minimum the last three years uh if their
special teams would have been better
they probably would have won this year
oh by the way they could go out and hire
rich pistachio who i think is the best
special teams coaching football so they
they're taking away every excuse that
aaron has
and dan what a tragedy it would be
for a guy that at the very minimum we
say is the most talented quarterback
we've ever seen at the very minimum you
could argue that he uh from an
individual's standpoint he's one of the
more accomplished quarterbacks winning
four mvps what a privacy that would be
if he only wins one super bowl and so i
think there's a lot of pressure on aaron
rodgers to win we don't know what
russell is going to be
like remember when i think it was the
eagles or the then known as the redskins
put that team together and we called him
a dream team and everybody's like man
they're going to dominate and they feel
terrible so we don't know what denver is
going to be we don't know what kind of
coach nathaniel hockey is going to be
i know what green bay and aaron are so
there's a ton of pressure on him yeah i
look at denver i'm not
they're not quite there yet but russ
does give you a chance to win every game
and you can't it's been a long time
since we've said that about a denver
quarterback there i'm curious what
seattle's doing pete carroll is going to
be 71
i try not to factor in age but when i
look at a rebuild for a team
at that age
and they haven't drafted well
um
i don't know what they have there bobby
wagner the heart and soul of that that
football team he's gone now russ is gone
drew locke
i mean unless they get lucky they draft
somebody or you know deshawn watson
comes to town
what what do you make of seattle's logic
here
well seattle i think realized that they
were the fourth best team in the nfc
west with russell wilson so if we're
gonna beat that let's not pay a guy 34
million dollars whatever he's owed this
year and be the fourth best team in our
division
the fact that they've gotten they've
traded russell they've gotten rid of
bobby ryan they're clearly rebuilding at
the very minimum now i just wonder why
they have a 17 and a half million safety
uh in in jamal adams um
that contract sticks out with what
they're doing so i don't know if they
can trade that contract so um
they're rebuilding but they can't really
all
kind of go all in on rebuilding because
of that contract so
i think pete carroll he's a young 70 if
there ever was a thing probably like you
know you then you're like a young 80. uh
i mean both you both you guys are kind
of in the same boat there uh younger
more vibrant than you really are and so
i think pete is probably saying
hey if we if we get super lucky super
lucky we can package our picks and be in
on desean watson if that legal situation
gets resolved if we get super lucky if
at the very worst we're going to have a
lot of pigs and if we like a quarterback
this year or next year we can draft one
and then we will be on a three to five
year trajectory to rebuild
do you remember running the 40 at the
combine
uh yes iran afforded the combine i was
tired as hell but i remember my time
like the meal i ate this morning
okay
that time was
uh and hopefully i got it right
485
paulie what do you have for booger yeah
booger mcfarland out of lsu at the nfl
combine 485 which one one of the fastest
all-time if he were one pound heavier
the he weighed in at 299 pounds if he
had weighed in at 300 you would have
been in a group with one of the fastest
300 plus pounders of all time in combine
history
so here's here's a little back story
today
uh we did a lot of testing the 40 time
was the last thing we do i was dog tired
etc i ran 485 at 299
at my pro day which was a month later
where the only thing i did was run i
weighed in at 302
and
i ran in
uh some waffle bottom track shoes that i
had gotten from the track team so at 302
there was a varying degree of times from
four five nine to four seven one that
day oh point
wow
that's impressive
uh and then here's the thing dan here's
the thing you got to realize i wasn't
six six like jordan davis or 340. so the
thing that made my game really
attractive to being a first round pick
was i was short thick and athletic
things that normally don't go together
but if you look at the best defensive
tackles i would argue over the last 25
years i'm gonna name them not that i am
in the category because i'm not but
let's take a look at him john randall
62 285
warren cell 62
280 5 290. aaron donald 6'1 285
you follow me like the best guys aren't
6667 the best guys or the short thick
extremely athletic defensive tackles
i know but i look at him at 6 6 if he
can't get to the quarterback
just putting those hands up
and how he could disrupt that defensive
line in a different way than what aaron
donald does aaron donald uses leverage
and he gets to the quarterback you know
this kid
if he doesn't get there you're going to
put his hands up and it's 6-6
going to make it really difficult for
you
i'll agree uh i think where he's drafted
is going to determine the expectations
that we have for him let's look at
cleveland pharaoh who was drafted fourth
overall by the raiders he's looked at as
a bus not because he's not a really good
player he's just not a sad guy and
that's where you expect or that's what
you expect him to be when you draft him
fourth overall so i think the
expectations are going to be relative to
where jordan davis is drafted if he's if
he's drafted in the top 10 based on that
combined performance it's going to be a
disappointment because he's never going
to be a sad guy to me he's sean rogers
remember sean rogers that played for the
lions sean rogers played 10 years you
know how many sacks he had in his career
37 so three sacks a year but sean rogers
was a good player he was he was kind of
dominant in his own way hello the nada
like this is the type of player i think
that jordan davis could be uh but the
one thing that concerns me about jordan
davis and i'm thinking if you ask any
defensive lineman who goes back and
watches the tape the biggest thing that
i think that can
deter him from being really good is he's
got to be able to do it not on play one
can he do it on play 24 can he do it
after he's had a meet friday at home can
he do it on plate 39 on sunday okay
that'll be the key then because he's got
to be in shape and it's hard to play
four quarters at six six three forty one
it's hard he's gotta get in better shape
because i can i can show you tape where
he literally walks off the ball against
alabama and stands there and doesn't
move like you have more movement now in
your neck than he had on that play and
that's embarrassing for a guy who turned
the combine upside down this weekend
always great to talk to you booger
thanks for joining us we appreciate it
anytime dan always uh i see my picture
still hasn't gotten over your head but
i'm still efforting yeah yeah once again
you know you got a jersey you got a
picture we we we we'll put it up here we
just don't want anything from dan
orlovsky because
you know
yes
marcus spears trying to muscle his way
in get some uh get something up here
behind me so just letting you know
you're not the only defensive lineman
i'm talking to
i love it i love it the jersey's on the
way thank you buddy that's booger
mcfarlane espn nfl and college football
analyst